>>> YO, WHAT UP?
IT'S YOUR BOY SOFT SPOT.
>> IT'S YOUR MAN, HEAVY DIAP.
>> AND ME ONESIE.
>> AND YO GIRL, BABY SNACKS.
>> WA, WA.
>> WE BABIES, SO YOU KNOW WHEN
WE GET DOWN YOU GOT DO THE BABY
STEP.
>> WA, WA.
>> LET'S DO IT, LARRY DAVID.
>> I SAID I'M NOT DOING THIS.
♪ HEY WHAT'S YOUR NAME
ON INSTA
WE TAKING BABY STEPS ♪
♪ IS YOU GONNA
PAY FOR DINNER
WE TAKING BABY STEPS
YO ♪
♪ DO THE BABY STEP
DO THE BABY STEP
DO THE BABY STEP ♪
>> I SAID I'M NOT DOING THIS.
DON'T CUT TO ME ANYMORE.
I'M SERIOUS.
COME ON.
♪ JUST SPEND A WEEK IN PARIS
WE TAKING BABY STEPS
WHEN AM I GOING TO
MEET YOUR PARENTS ♪
♪ WE TAKING BABY STEPS ♪
♪ DO THE BABY STEP
DO THE BABY STEP
DO THE BABY STEP ♪
♪ THIS IS LENNY
SHE SIPS HENNEY
SHE SAID HOW OLD ARE YOU
I SAID THIS MANY ♪
♪ I'M IN MY TERRIBLE TWOS
SO I DON'T CARE WHAT I DO
I AIN'T PREPARED
FOR NO RULES ♪
♪ I AIN'T WEARING
NO SHOES ♪
>> OH, NO, NO, NO.
>> HERE'S YOUR BONNET.
>> BONNET?
NO.
THAT'S --
ENOUGH.
ENOUGH!
>>> WE UP IN THE CLUB GETTING
THE BABIES POPPING.
THE BABIES GET TO POPPING.
AND SHE LOVE THAT.
SHE LOVE THAT.
SHE A RUG RAT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
CUT IT.
OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
KEENAN, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YOU ARE WEARING A DIAPER?
FOR THIS?
COME ON.
YOU KNOW, I CAN SEE CARL HERE
DOING IT BECAUSE IT'S HIS FIRST
YEAR.
BUT YOU?
I MEAN, HOW LONG DO YOU HAVE
HERE NOT TO DO THIS KIND OF
STUFF?
>> I WISH I KNEW.
>> YEAH, ME TOO.
NICE GOING, MILEY.
>> HI LARRY.
>> COME ON.
>> LARRY, MY NAME IS CHRIS.
>>.
♪ DO THE BABY STEP, DO THEN BABY
STEP.
>> ARE YOU GUYS MAD AT ME.
>> YOU ARE GOING TO EDIT ME OUT
OF THIS, RIGHT.
>> I PROMISE YOU WON'T BE IN IT
AT ALL.
I PROMISE.
>> WE GONNA BE IN IT.
♪♪♪
MUSIC